hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
gonna answer a question from one of my
newsletter readers wakil who wrote
insane let me scroll up here I want to
ask you what should I do to stop illegal
and free sharing of e-books he's in the
e-book publishing in industry and when
people buy his ebooks he finds that
people are sharing them through various
sharing websites and it's losing him a
lot of money so what to do thanks to the
question a common problem for a lot of
people who are in publishing or any kind
of publishing really there's not a whole
lot you can do unfortunately and so
here's what I would do and I'm in this
industry as well so I have worksheets
that I sell for entrepreneurs and we
have 32 up now we're gonna have 50 or 60
and and they're downloadable products
that are for sale and unfortunately
sometimes people will share them with
others for free without giving you no
credit back and paying for it my best
strategy here for you what I would try
to do is showcase that you are a small
company right so a lot of time people do
this because obviously looking for a
deal but also they don't want to pay the
big guys lots of money so when you're
selling a product you can ask them
please don't share this and tell your
story and say you're a small company you
know it's hard you're trying to get this
business off the ground then every sale
is important if you have you know your
face if you have a video or at least
just explanation of your story just to
make an emotional connection because
some people are so used to sharing these
files that they don't care they don't
give it a second thought it's what
they're gonna do so if you can have some
kind of emotional connection to let them
know that every sale really is important
to you and that you're not some big huge
profitable company but a small business
and you're trying to get it going
that might help make sure that they
don't share it it's not a legal way
there's no way to actually enforce it
but you'll find that if people you know
get that emotional connection then you
know they may think twice about it so
when you are asked
people for the sale or after they
purchased it you have a thank you page
you can put down as part of your message
if you're really worried about it
happening the next thing you can do is
if you know who is actually doing the
sharing then you can try to reach out to
them and again with a personal message I
wouldn't try to do any kind of legal
action but try to just explain again
you're a small business this is really
hurting you and if they wouldn't mind
taking it down that's only if you know
them often can be hard to find out who
the person is who's sharing it but that
that's a tactic again you're just
appealing to their the good in them and
and it can help if if you can actually
identify who the person is
next thing is potentially doing some
kind of legal action and going after the
websites who are publishing it if it's a
big website like Pirate Bay you know
good luck there's huge companies who are
trying to take them down already if
something just put it up on their own
website you may be able to reach out to
them and say you know can you please
take it down but if it's one of the
bigger file sharing sites you don't
really have a lot of options here there
are some people who will never pay for
products and it really just depends on
how convenient it is for them so even
going to these file sharing sites there
is some work involved versus just
somebody landing on your website and
making that purchase so some people
value their their time a lot more than
their money and some people value their
money a lot more than their time so the
guys who will spend two hours trying to
find a free copy of a five dollar book
they're probably not going to buy from
you right they're not your ideal
customer maybe they might be at some
point it's usually you know younger
people don't have a lot of money they're
willing to spend a lot of their time but
not their money on things and as they
get older and as they have more money
disposable income they start valuing
their time more and they'll spend the
money because it'll save them half an
hour or an hour to try to find something
so there's not a lot you can do with it
what I would try to do is is use your
current books that are being sold to
also market other potential books so if
something is being downloaded for free
and one of the file sharing sites and
you can't really impact it too much
within each of your books have a promo
call back to your website
other related books so even if it is
going to somebody for free there's some
kind of call to action that you might be
able to get somebody on your newsletter
or back to your website or following in
social media so that hopefully they can
come into your engine and there's some
way to follow up with them and hopefully
they can't become a customer in the
not-too-distant future so I know it's a
big challenge and sorry to hear that's
really hurt in your business those are
the steps that I would do so again have
some kind of personal message when
somebody is buying them your products
and curtam not to share it if you know
who is doing it try to reach out to them
well again with a personal appeal if you
see the websites and they're not too big
you know talk to them and again stress
how important this is because you're a
small business and then for the ones
that are still leaking through to the
sites have some kind of marketing
message within your ebooks at the end or
at the beginning or some kind of
watermark so that people will hopefully
come back to your website sign up your
newsletter take whatever next
call-to-action you have hopefully that
helps those of you watching if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below makes fun of do more for you and
if you have a comment about this video
or another question for your own
business feel free to leave it in the
comments below I always read those and I
try to respond everybody who does ask
question so thank you and I'll see you
on the next episode
you